[Musique]
mais ce qui était prévu mais attend
pourtant très ouverte c'est chelou
ouverte pas fermée à clef ou ouverte
ouverte termes d'anne 15 à la maison a
été fouillée
ça c'est sûrement 14 sur toi de là
[Musique]
allez ça
m
[Musique]
mais
suite à ces commence à gâcher des
cachets ou
[Musique]
derrière le canapé sort de là
m
tu sais ce que je veux tu veux rester en
vie alors gagnant du temps dis moi tout
de suite où nous apparaît ne seront pas
desservis
oui le dernier rue gauche dis moi oui le
dernier rue gauche je t'explose la
cervelle taqwa écoutez moi bien croyez
vous écoute
si vous me cherchez pas c'est ça votre
compréhension
désolé pour la gêne occasionnée c'est
compliqué aujourd'hui
ouais c'est clair laisse tomber le boost
en jeu le ternir la gauche votre
attention s'il vous plaît une deuxième
réalisation
et là tu as très bien entendu les
questions caddoc tas de petits numéros
caddoc le dernière egos il est là je me
réponds tout carette
[Musique]
depuis 17 ans maman et accomplir la
prophétie
je disais depuis le temps que j'attends
ce moment depuis tant que tu attends
maman non moment ce moment là c'est tost
le l'instant présent à l'instant présent
tu veux me faire un cadeau danger
baptisa l'instant présent en prison pour
le moment y'a aucun rapport à ma mère et
de quoi depuis tant que tu attends ce
moment en quoi ce jeu là continue tu
montes tout le temps tous comment veux
tu que je tienne prêt depuis le temps
que tu as en ce moment quoi j'attends ce
moment je vais pas cracher ton oeil vous
écoutez je n'entends rien fait un pas
vers moi je vais entendre non dans quoi
tu me fais un procès pénal comme par
hasard mais un piège sur sous la
moquette yens 3 buts et 2 roues ou des
merdes comme ça tu crois que tu sembles
non t'as qu'à lire sur mes lèvres parce
qu'on n'arrive pas à se faire comprendre
là tu vas tout de suite me donne est on
à gauche sinon je vais te tuer je sais
pas lire sur les lèvres butin et les
gars vous prenez pas la tête et regarde
pas de toute façon
[ __ ] mais l'aventuré coin dans son
annonce à lui la salle est finie la
barre avait de l'eau cas sérieusement
parce qu on serrera qui paraît qu'un mec
la république promet de bourges on est
en train d'y vraiment super important là
c'est ce que je vous dis à chaque fois
mais elle est d'accord avec toi attendre
jusque là tu en sais pas comment ça ok
exact pour chanter on chante et on
regarde toi quel week end c'était pas
mal ça a c'est trop ouf
moi j'adore personnes enfermées pouze et
toi tu regardes quoi iron vikings ok
c'est bien ça va ça fait mal mais je
n'ai jamais vu dans le plus cela
provoque tu prends à banon je le prends
tous les jours pour aller à la fac moi
parce que ça prouve pas que je vois tes
yeux
je veux dire s'il avait dû habiter yeux
je m'en serais sous le lourd
ah ok d'accord pour cette aide aux cours
à la fac
welch à la faille en psycho mais mes
horaires c'est un peu n'importe quoi du
coup parfois je fais pas non plus trop
bas parfois t'es pas trop bon on abrège
là c'est pas vrai et attend quoi moi je
suis en ciné ok c'est cool moi c'est
cool mais et c'est quoi alors les cours
on étudie l'histoire du cinéma
on fait des analyses de films un peu
juste super en pleine bataille finale
alors que je viens de perdre mon
meilleur ami pas encore tout à fait
c'est cool parce que le gars ça faisait
longtemps qu'elle avait repérée grattant
t'emballe pas non plus c'est pas fait
attention et aucun raison c'est beau
parce qu'elle est insupportable qui ont
forcément super chaud j'allais te
défoncer c'est un moment fatidique va
revenir halde à calais met toi bien tu
vas me défoncer
[Musique]
c'est ici que gadio a émis un signal
pour la dernière fois donc ça correspond
le professeur à verizon
ça ne fait aucun doute ça correspond
parfaitement cette fois-ci c'est nous
qui avons un code avoir sur lui c'est
notre dernière chance d'arrêter la
prophétie rigueur c'est qu'ils ont dans
les temps
bon bah il a lâché la série reviendra
pas ils partagent sans compter avec son
petit frère moi je mise tout sur le
petit frère c'est une petite soeur qui
l'a à j'avoue c'est chaud
[Musique]
action j'ai jamais réussi à faire ces
conneries
et voilà fait voir j'en ai c'est une
comme ça
action
[Musique]